donc je dépose mes enfants en train de
foot et puis après comme j'avais une
heure devant moi j'ai décidé d'aller
faire des petites courses à Lidl donc je
fais mes courses normalement dans le
magasin et j'arrive à la caisse il y a
trois personnes qui se sont fait
agresser d'ailleurs à ma place du moins
j'aurais dû être à leur place donc ils
m'ont laissé gentiment passer parce que
j'avais que 3 articles d'accord et puis
arrivé à la caisse quand j'ai payé mes
articles j'ai entendu des cris mais je
pensais que c'était une bagarre donc
j'ai mis deux trois secondes à réaliser
que en fait voilà c'était un homme qui a
agressé des gens avec deux armes
blanches donc il avait une arme dans
chaque main donc un hachoir c'est ça
moi j'avais vu de hachoirs mais bon la
police dit un hachoir et puis une lame
un couteau de boucher ouais de 30 cm
donc j'ai mis deux trois secondes quand
j'ai vu du sang quand j'ai vu du sang
j'ai compris que il y avait quelque
chose de grave donc il y avait une
cliente forcément donc exactement
il y avait une cliente juste avant moi
qui a été avec une petite fille donc qui
a pris sa fille qui s'est enfui parce
que la porte de sortie était juste à
côté elle a laissé son caddie juste
devant moi et donc il fallait intervenir
donc spontanément donc là il était là le
la saillant il était quoi il était à
quelques il était 2 mètres
il touchait tout ce qui bougeait tout ce
qu'il y avait autour de lui puis les les
gens et rien rien et rien du tout il a
même pas un seul on l'a vu il a pris il
était il a sorti de hachoir il a
commencé à se mettre je pense qu'il a
préparé qu'il avait déjà préparé dans le
magasin parce qu'il est rentré faire ses
courses comme si de rien il a blessé
quatre personnes c'est ça il a blessé 4
personnes dont moi et puis les trois
deux personnes à la caisse puis une
personne après quand il est parti une
jeune fille justement une Belge qui
venait de qui venait pour la première
fois faire faire ses courses en France
elle s'est pris deux coups de hache
pareil rester pétrifié de peur devant
lui
et puis alors là donc vous là vous avez
le chariot qui est qui avait laissé la
dame donc là vous décidez de prendre le
chariot ma spontanément j'ai dit voilà
comme lui il a des armes vous pensez pas
partir à ce moment-là parce que comme
vous dites la dame est partie juste
devant vous dites pas je vais partir
vous dites non je n'ai aucun moment à
aucun moment c'est venu c'est venu dans
mon esprit ah oui je revois encore les
images de l'agression voilà du sang qui
gicle de la tête de quelqu'un c'était
c'était bon alors aujourd'hui c'était
non assistant non assistance à personne
en danger si je partais à ce moment-là
et puis donc spontanément j'ai pris le
caddie pour remettre une distance entre
moi et lui il a quand même réussi à me
toucher à me toucher à la tête une
blessure superficielle puis comme il
avait deux armes donc après j'ai foncé
dessus avec le caddie et quand j'ai
voulu profiter du choc pour essayer de
lui sauter dessus pour bah pour le
maîtriser ou le mettre par terre ou
faire quelque chose c'est là qu'il m'a
mis un deuxième coup qui m'a tranché il
m'a tranché de doigts de doigts donc
j'ai pu quand même le pousser après j'ai
couru à l'intérieur du magasin j'ai
glissé dans une marre de sang j'ai
paniqué parce que vous savez pas si me
suivait ou pas donc j'ai essayé de me
relever tout en regardant derrière moi
et quand j'ai vu qu'il bah en fait qu'il
est parti dans le fond du magasin c'est
à ce moment là qu'il a agressé la jeune
la jeune fille belge
à ce moment-là et puis quand je me suis
relevé et ben là comme il est parti dans
son magasin tous les tous les tous les
victimes qu'on était à la caisse mais on
a tous pris bah voilà la sortie et puis
et puis aller se mettre à l'abri le plus
rapidement possible et là là il vient
quoi lui alors à ce moment-là ma
dernière nouvelle que j'ai eu
apparemment il a été interné en
psychiatrie donc il a été interpellé
juste après et en fait il s'est tranché
les veines et la carotide donc il est
parti il est parti se donner la mort
dans la réserve quand il a vu qu'il y
avait plus de bah plus de victimes plus
de proie dans le magasin il est parti
pendant la réserve et puis il a voulu
mettre fin à sa vie
vous avez été pris en charge bien
entendu très vite par les secours
qu'est-ce qu'il en est de vos deux
doigts là qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai
été amputé donc d'une phalange de la
lunaire et mon majeur et le mettre le
SOS ma Valenciennes ils ont su à
quoi je l'ai récupéré moi-même c'est ça
exactement et là vous avez remis votre
en fait dans l'état de choc je suis il y
a ma cousine qui habite à 100 mètres du
Lidl donc je suis parti chez elle
d'ailleurs je fais un hommage parce que
parce que c'est elle qui m'a voilà c'est
la première personne qui m'a qui m'a
apporté qui m'a apporté de l'aide donc
j'ai été chez elle pour pour calmer en
fait aux urgences donc c'était un peu
flou je disais voilà appelé aux urgences
appelle la police et puis quand on est
parti quand elle m'a emmené en voiture
je lui dis bah viens on va à Lidl je
vais récupérer le bout de mon doigt ah
ouais donc
exactement elle est venue avec moi Lidl
sans réfléchir quand j'y repense à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même
c'est quand même dingue
il y avait quand même la police
nationale qui était arrivée sur place
qu'ils avaient pas encore ils avaient
pas encore trouvé la l'agresseur donc là
je rentre dans le Lidl et à la police
qui voilà qui me prévient que qui me
demande voilà mon identité je suis qui
donc je leur explique un peu la
situation je lui dis à la policière bah
il y a mon doigt qui est juste à la
caisse je les récupère pour aller à
l'hôpital c'est donc même moi quand je
vous en parle alors d'aujourd'hui je me
dis que c'est quand même incroyable
parce qu'en fait je vous explique il y a
quelques années de ça mon père dans son
jardin et s'est coupé la main avec une
tondeuse et il a pas récupéré son doigt
sur le coup donc voilà il a perdu
exactement une femme donc moi c'est
tellement resté imprégné il faut que
j'aille le exactement en état de choc
c'est la première chose qui me suis venu
à l'esprit et puis
et puis donc allemand on est rentré dans
le magasin et c'est elle qui a ramassé
mon bout de doigt donc je lui dis tiens
mon mon doigt il est là elle a ramassé
elle l'a mis dans sa poche puis là le
SMUR les pompiers sont tous arrivés
voilà ils nous ont pris en charge et
puis ils l'ont mis dans la glace donc
exactement et ça et là on te l'a
regretté en fait comme j'avais compressé
j'avais des gants comme j'avais compris
c'est ma main
assez longtemps l'artère c'est bouché
les vaisseaux sanguins sont bouchés donc
le chirurgien m'a dit on peut essayer de
remettre le doigt mais ça sera un bout
de phalange morte au bout au bout au
bout de la main quoi et puis et puis si
si la greffe marche pas s'il est pas
alimenté il faudra refaire une
amputation donc refaire donc moi j'ai il
m'a donné le choix et j'ai dit bah
autant voilà autant le laisser couper
quoi exactement autant amputé et puis ça
oui ça sera moins désagréable c'est
incroyable votre histoire franchement
bravo bravo à vous et 500 francs je sais
que
les forces de police ensuite ce que vous
avez reçu des appels de
ça fait trois semaines que mon téléphone
il arrête pas de sonner je sais même pas
où donner de la tête mais là c'est c'est
un élan voilà il y a un élan de
solidarité voilà on est tous réunis ici
on est tous des Français on est tous
dans le même bateau
est-ce qu'on est-ce que vous allez avoir
une distinction
je sais pas du tout je sais pas c'est
vrai que voilà
c'est incroyable ça vous ferait plaisir
ou pas bien sûr tout ce qui met à
l'honneur tout ce qui met à l'honneur
bien sûr qu'on qu'on est preneur est-ce
que vous avez regretté un moment est-ce
que vous êtes pas dit parce que on l'a
vu voilà vous êtes vous êtes amputé de
de doigts est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
dire un moment il faudrait peut-être pas
dû j'aurais dû partir honnêtement si
c'était une arme à feu je pense que
le ma réaction aurait été différente
mais alors d'aujourd'hui quand je vois
par exemple mes je vois mes enfants j'ai
trois enfants je leur fais d'ailleurs
leur faire un gros le réseau à mes
enfants que voilà ils disent que je suis
un héros quand on sort dans la rue ils
disent voilà c'est mon papa c'est le
héros donc voilà c'est aussi pour eux un
exemple voilà un exemple à suivre et
puis pour toute vous êtes un exemple
tous les jeunes et puis si demain voilà
si demain une agression voilà une
personne
assiste à une agression et il faut
absolument absolument intervenir parce
que on peut pas laisser faire comme ça
des injustices d'agressions
sans comment dire sans sans réagir c'est
incroyable
c'est fou c'est c'est un vrai héros
alors il y a une autre personne qui a
été blessée Sullivan qui lui dit qu'il a
du mal maintenant à sortir et cetera
vous vous avez l'air vous raconter
l'histoire vous n'avez pas de stress
c'est le cauchemar est passé dans votre
esprit parce que en fait à la base mot
il m'a pas il m'a pas agressé
directement par exemple Sullivan les
deux personnes les a il est venu par
derrière donc il leur a signé des coût
de hache et s'il attendait même pas moi
je l'ai vu moi je l'ai vu en face à face
donc j'ai pu appréhender même les les
coûts qui m'a mis d'ailleurs la main il
m'a sectionné parce que lui il m'a visé
à la tête à la base donc c'est moi qui
me protège avec ma main et sur le coup
voilà c'est la seule chose que c'est la
chaussure que j'avais donc je me suis
protégé avec ma main c'est pour ça qu'il
mectionne la mort mais lui voilà les
deux personnes est venu par derrière
donc eux ils étaient imaginez-vous vous
êtes à la caisse en train pour payer
pour passer vos articles puis il y a
quelqu'un qui vient par derrière qui
vous assène d'écoute h comme ça c'est
incroyable c'est terrible c'est terrible
à 20h terrible c'est fou et bravo on dit
dans on a dit dans le petit récap que
vous vous avez toujours la tête de de la
saillant dans dans en vous comme vous le
voulez vous le revoyez vous arrivez je
vois exactement puis je revois voilà le
souvent la scène parce que justement en
fait voilà je revois encore bah écoute h
à la tête et c'est vrai c'est terrible
j'ai plus mal quand je repense à à ces
images que que que à ma main
c'est la première à m'avoir fait un
hommage donc héros donc voilà je
l'embrasse aussi on l'embrasse aussi
moi j'ai envie de penser que n'importe
qui aurait réagi de la même façon que
moi
ça c'est les vrais hommes parce que
n'importe qui ne l'aurais pas fait moi
scandalisé quand j'entends dans le métro
une femme c'est fait agresser il y avait
60 passagers tout le monde est parti
dans le fond du train il suffirait juste
que tout le monde se jette sur le mec et
ça n'arriverait plus alors c'est facile
à dire mais ça c'est les vrais héros
quand tes enfants disent que tu as un
héros moi je te le dis tu es un vrai
bonhomme parce que y aller devant un
hachoir moi j'aurais peut-être fait
comme toi une arme à feu je me serais
peut-être barré un hachoir j'aurais
peut-être été mais c'est ce que tu as
fait c'est très fort ça c'est un vrai
bonhomme il en faut des mecs comme ça
dans tes films
je pense je pense que effectivement une
arme à peu près
non non je pense que je vais peut-être
le j'aurais pu essayer peut-être je mais
vous savez quoi on ne sait jamais
comment on réagira non non on sait
jamais on sait jamais ce qui se passe
dans la tête des gens donc moi je pense
et la vérité non ce que je me serais
barré merci
Jean Gabin magnifique
on est pas tous des héros Benjamin
monsieur
c'est incroyable je pense que on en a
parlé tout à l'heure avec Tarik je pense
que dans certaines situations on
réfléchit pas parce que c'est l'instinct
de survie qui joue partir c'est pas la
meilleure des choses à faire et
d'ailleurs ce qu'il donne comme anecdote
c'est que plus que la douleur que la
blessure qui avait son doigt
c'est-à-dire que l'instinct de survie
c'est on est tous capable de s'en aller
on est tous capables de tuer quelqu'un
on est tous capable de faire des choses
qu'on soupçonnerait même pas là le
chariot tout ce qu'il a pu faire il
savait que de toute façon si il faisait
pas il allait ramasser
c'est fou un Guillaume moi honnêtement
j'aurais fait ma couille mal je pense
réparti mais franchement ce qui me
fascine c'est qu'il a il a il a pas du
tout eu peur l'impression que vous avez
même pas eu le temps d'avoir peur en
fait pas le temps c'est ça on n'a pas le
temps comme j'ai dit c'est une réaction
spontanée donc si on se met à réfléchir
bah voilà
et le chariot aussi providentiel quoi
c'était même pas réfléchi tu t'es dit je
peux mettre quelque chose entre lui et
moi est un foncé dessus et que les
chariots exactement c'est magnifique
j'ai aussi la présence d'esprit voilà
prendre ce chariot que la dame a posé
exactement donc ça c'est organisé en un
millième de seconde je remercie Dieu
d'avoir laissé ce caddie devant moi pour
exactement pouvoir voilà pour pouvoir
intervenir parce que peut-être aussi
s'il y avait pas le cas dit peut-être
que j'aurais aussi réagir
ils veulent plus payer les gens
en tout cas en tout cas j'espère que tu
auras une distinction à la prochaine
dans la prochaine promotion la Légion
d'honneur sur la légende ah oui la
Légion d'honneur
de toute façon même pour des
distinctions vu les gens qui ont été
distingués cette année n'est pas de
regrets l'année prochaine ça sera mieux
voilà
bravo bravo à toi et je peux dire que ta
famille et tes enfants qui te regarde
doivent être fier de toi et ta femme
aussi et tu fais quoi dans la vie bah
j'étais en reconversion professionnelle
en horlogerie d'accord parce que je suis
originaire de Jeumont mais j'ai ça fait
10 ans que j'habite à la frontière
Haute-Savoie donc je travaille en Suisse
j'étais en reconversion parce que je me
suis fait opérer quatre fois quatre fois
du genou
donc j'étais j'avais un métier où c'est
physique donc j'étais en recouvert ce
professionnel là tu continues là-dessus
tu vas continuer là-dessus bah avec la
main avec maman après moi je suis en
train de je suis en train de essayer de
trouver des solutions pour me retourner
donc est-ce que tu vois là tu vois sur
un sur un cas comme ça est-ce que tu vas
voir des aides est-ce que tu vas voir
est-ce que tu as eu des gens qui te
disent des propositions non mais même
plus même parce que est-ce qu'il y a des
il y a des aides du gouvernement je sais
pas parce qu'aujourd'hui mais non tu as
eu un geste héroïque tu vois moi je suis
là je je te dis ça parce que j'avais pas
du tout anticipé suite à allait me dire
tu me dis que je travaille dans
l'horlogerie c'est vrai que forcément ça
va plus compliqué pour toi maintenant tu
as eu un gestéroïde comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui est-ce que je pose la
question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui peut-être
le pays va mettre en place quelque chose
pour lui ce qu'ils vont essayer de lui
trouver quelque chose est-ce qu'on va
essayer de l'aider parce que
ou le maire ou je sais même et même si
je peux me permettre l'idole hein
sans rigoler on fait un appel à Lidl
même les autres si vous voulez j'adore
l'idole en plus donc j'ai été contacté
par Lidl qui m'a dit que leur assurance
allait nous revenir vers moi assez
rapidement et peut-être que tu as
peut-être un truc
on étudie toutes les petites très bien
en tout cas tu nous tiendras au courant
Tariq et bravo
[Applaudissements]